Hi, I'm Lauren. I'm one of the instructors
for Introduction to Psychology.
I want to use this course to show you
why I love psychology so much.
Psychology helps us understand and answer
questions about thought and behavior.
For example, how does operant conditioning
make Maddie here so excited
when I say, psychology!
Good girl, Maddie.
Hi, I'm Greg. And I'm Susan,
and we're also your instructors
for this general psychology course.
You just saw Lauren provide an example
of operant conditioning with Maddie.
But you're going to learn
much more in this course.
You're also going to learn about things
such as sensation and perception,
personality, and even mental disorders
and treatments for those disorders.
But you don't actually need
a real background in psychology.
All you need is a curiosity about
human behavior and human nature.
And if you bring that
to this class, we promise
it'll be an exciting adventure for you.